[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es einen 20
minuten mittagessen rezept dass hier
alle lieben werdet film machen schicken
alfredo und geht so schnell ist cremig
lecker und einfache woche noch wenige
zutaten ich fange direkt an und schreibe
euch alle ganz genauen mengen unten in
die video beschreibung ich fange an mit
meinem hähnchen das werde ich jetzt
erstmal in mundgerechte stücke schneiden
ich mache sie so ein bisschen länglicher
und falls eure hähnchenbrüste doch ein
bisschen zu dick ist und das nicht ganz
so mundgerecht ist dann könnt ihr hier
gerne in der mitte noch einmal halbieren
und dann das ganze schön schneiden
[Musik]
sondern jetzt das hähnchen in der
beschichteten pfanne anbraten nicht
nehmen da gern stufe 7 9
und ich nehme auch kokosöl das
designierte das ist nämlich
geschmacksneutral und das kann man auch
ruhig hoch erhitzen gleichkommt noch
olivenöl zum einsatz wegen des
geschmacks aber nicht jetzt beim rat
fordern und während ich die von beiden
seiten anbraten welches noch salzen und
pfeffern
[Musik]
das hähnchen braucht nur zwei bis drei
minuten von ihrer seite also bloß nicht
zu lange anbraten sonst wird es trocken
ich habe jetzt hier schon mal raus
genommen und in derselben fahne werde
ich jetzt fein gehackte zwiebeln und
knoblauch andünsten
champignons kommen auch mit dazu aber
schaltet nicht ab wenn ich keine
champignons mit ihr könnten sie auch
weglassen aber ich finde es ist schon
eine super wichtige zutat weil
einerseits gibt es nochmal geschmack ab
und es macht auch so ein bisschen was
mit der seligkeit wie ich finde
aber ich habe es auch schon mal ohne
champignons gemacht weil haben sie das
jetzt auch nicht so der größte
champignons aber okay
[Musik]
so hier ist zwar noch rest von unserem
hähnchen drin aber ich muss unbedingt
noch butter und olivenöl mit dazu allein
schon für den geschmack zwiebeln und
knoblauch werden jetzt mit butter und
olivenöl drei minuten lang gedünstet und
ich kümmere mich in der zwischenzeit um
die champignons die habe ich geputzt
wird sie in feine scheiben schneiden und
kann sie jetzt machen drei minuten
eigentlich schon direkt mit dazugeben
und hinzu kommen dann auch noch die
hähnchenbrust streifen und sahne da
könnt ihr euch jetzt aussuchen nimmt die
ganz normale voll fett variante nehmt
ihr die fettarme ich habe heute zum
beispiel diese fettarme sahne genommen
das mache ich auch immer ganz gerne hat
mir nicht so ein schlechtes gewissen ich
glaube die hat halb so viel fett wie
normale seine 15 das gebe ich auch noch
mit dazu und dann wird nur noch mit salz
und pfeffer gewürzt
[Musik]
jetzt durfte bei mir auf mittlerer stufe
alles nochmal vier maximal fünf minuten
köcheln und wir sind fast fertig das
ging ja wirklich rückzug ist es halt
perfekt für den alltag wenn man einfach
was richtig leckeres möchte aber nicht
so viel zeit investieren will
ich gebe jetzt noch meine gar gekochten
tagen der teller dazu können auch
verschiedene wir können auch panel
nehmen was ihnen möchte ich gerade
schnell gar gekocht in salzwasser es
gebe ich jetzt noch mit dazu den herd
habe ich übrigens ausgeschaltet und das
darf jetzt noch so acht bis zehn minuten
darin einfach ruhen und dann werdet ihr
merken dass auch die nudeln jetzt gerade
al dente sind auch noch mal so ein
bisschen was aufsaugen und richtig alles
richtig schön cremig wird es ist einfach
so lecker
[Musik]
hamza der champignon nicht mag ich war
immer raus sich airbus kündigt ihre
dafür nicht rausholen probiert einfach
mal du bist du für dein text ist bekannt
soll ich nehme was sind das für coole
kokos adel in den kokons alle mega
stylish deutschen clubteams kindchen
drauf
das coole ist diese kokos schalen die
kommen von den philippinen von so einer
kleinen fabrik die die eigentlich weg
geschmissen hätten und wir haben sie
quasi gerettet und ich finde auch mega
stylischen bald mal so schöne bolz
machen das mit ibolt for vision
ach so ich bin das spannende cremig
karma oder es kein these drin ist so
cremig
hier wird so weil ich sage es bitte
schön
ich habe damals eine rein gemacht und du
merkst 0 denkbar dass wirklich krank
cremig kann man jetzt noch nicht so sehr
ist die so cremig ist vor allem auch
immer so bleiben
also hängt bh ist vor allem vor allem
ich habe auch keine zum binden oder so
genommen rezepten wenig zutaten und
einfach nur lecker als lästiger favorit
kims irgendwie hast du die comcom dass
kriege und magazine sowie das ist das
gleiche
auf jeden fall ich finde den peter sitte
gibst du den richtigen krieg normaler
hätte ich ja auch schon das schmeckt man
kaufen können die ganze fahrt kommt mit
seinen wir setzen uns das mal hören und
genießen es aber nicht gereicht
also ich möchte das gar nicht glauben
ich habe auch ex aufgabe das ist nicht
genug
das ist bestimmt ein sofern ihr uns drin
ist bestimmt aber ich würde keine
stimmen wenn ein bisschen schlampig
fenster wenn es zu viel ist mag es aber
der geschmack von schon cool aber den
konsens mag ich nicht
deswegen verstehe ich mag diese
champignons pur vom grill und so bin ich
doch nicht so
die konsistent sein ich habe das ist
echt gut wirklich klemisch sehr lecker
und einstellung sehr schnell wenn ihr
nicht verdreht dann seid ihr ansonsten
und fertig also wenn ihr noch mehr
solcher gene rezepte möchtet was müsst
ihr tun und hier abonnieren leuten genau
die glocke aktivieren denn wir laden
nicht immer zur unzeit da kommt
vielleicht doch mal ein extra video
nicht nur eins oder zwei die woche
vollkommen noch mehr extra videos ja
eine planungs coole umwege nach machen
und wir sehen uns dann und in den
kommentaren oder im nächsten video
[Musik]
okay das ist was lustiges ich war dabei
gar nicht gemerkt dass gemacht
hmm
[Musik]
gut